[Música]
bienvenidos de nuevo a directo con 26 el
programa especial de france 24 para
debatir lo que ocurre en la cumbre
climática de la onu en glasgow más de 30
países incluidos algunos de los
principales fabricantes de automóviles
se comprometieron a dejar de producir
carros de combustión para el año 2035
esta fuente de contaminación es
responsable del 24 por ciento de
emisiones globales
el acuerdo tiene entre sus firmantes más
de 100 entidades que abarcan algunos de
los mayores mercados en la materia eeuu
o china y japón-
de otra parte del presidente de la cob
26 a lux arma difundió ya un primer
borrador del acuerdo de la cumbre del
clima en este insta a todos los estados
participantes a revisar sus objetivos de
reducción de emisiones para el 2030
vamos ahora con nuestra enviada especial
a glasgow marina colorado para más
detalles adelante marina
pues si angela y como bien decías el
tema de la jornada era el transporte sin
embargo se vio opacado por la
publicación como también mencionabas de
este primer boceto que ha dejado
reacciones mixtas y quien mejor para
hablar acerca de los detalles de este
primer boceto que alguien que está aquí
como observadora de cómo avanzan las
negociaciones ella es fernanda carvalho
encargada de políticas de clima y
energía de wwf el fondo mundial para la
naturaleza muchísimas gracias por estar
en france 24 primero reacciones de w w a
este boceto
creemos que está bueno pero es como el
mínimo hay como cosas que queríamos ver
pero tenemos más dos días de
negociaciones de todo puede cambiar pero
hay avances y hay avances en términos de
una llamada a los países para que
revisen sus metas sus objetivos para
2030 esto es importante
pero nos gustaría que fuera más fuerte y
había más detalles
hay también una mención a combustibles
fósiles de subsidios esto es súper
importante
también soluciones basadas en la
naturaleza entonces está bien pero es el
mínimo puede mejorar necesitamos más
pero este mínimo debe quedar y es la
primera vez desde el acuerdo de parís
porque no estaban incluidos ni los las
soluciones basadas en la naturaleza ni
la mención a combustibles fósiles porque
son tan importantes estas menciones en
este texto que ojalá quede en el texto
final porque como recordemos esto
simplemente es un boceto porque
soluciones basadas de naturaleza son
importantes porque tenemos como 56 por
ciento de las emisiones de co2
absorbidas por ecosistemas entonces es
muy necesario que sean preservados
conservados para mantenernos en 1.5
grados de día de aumento de temperatura
entonces esto es muy importante
combustibles fósiles claro combustibles
fósiles es lo que la ciencia apunta como
la causa principal de las emisiones de
gases de efecto enfermo invernadero
entonces tenemos que abordar estas cosas
aquí estas cosas son vistas en
2017 pero tenerlas conectadas con esto
aquí es muy importante el primer
ministro británico de boris johnson dijo
hace unos minutos en conferencia de
prensa que alcanzar el máximo de grado y
medio de aumento de temperaturas del
planeta aún es posible desde wwf como lo
ven ustedes tras leer este primer boceto
del texto
es posible pero precisamos más espacio
en el texto como una buena intención
como una intención de todos los países
pero hay que tener voluntad de política
por detrás entonces necesitamos que sean
más concretos los planes que haya como
fechas para que las cosas se pasen esto
no está en él en el texto todavía y
finalmente brevemente como observadores
cuál es su papel realmente para que la
gente entienda qué hace un observador
aquí en la copa estamos aquí para decir
a los países desde el mundo todo cuáles
son las prioridades y que falta y que
está bien que no estalló yo acompaño
pops y desde algunos años años yo creo
que las cosas mejoran y las cosas pasan
porque hay gente que observándolo pues
muchísimas gracias por su trabajo por su
labor aquí en la 26 y por su tiempo en
france 24 y a ustedes seguiremos como
cada día anunciando les las últimas
noticias que llegan desde
gracias.marina y france24 mantiene el
cubrimiento constante de la 26 siga con
nosotros ya volvemos con más
[Música]